hello everyone and welcome to this super
amazing video by simply love it is not
unknown that Tech organization are
pushing the boundaries of innovation Sam
Altman the CEO of open AI the company
that created chargpt said that AI can
probably be the end of the world but in
the meantime there will be many great AI
companies not to join the hype about how
AI will eliminate your jobs this video
is to Showcase some amazing and
Innovative tools that have announced in
the Google input output 2023 Google one
of the world's largest tech Giants in
its latest input output 2023 showcase
the latest and greatest AI Technologies
as a company Google has always been at
the Forefront of developing cutting-edge
AI tools and Technologies and this year
is no exception for revolutionary
language models to groundbreaking
robotics we have a lot of share with you
today so grab on to your seats and stay
tuned with us so we can discuss some of
the amazing innovations that Google has
done in the field of artificial
intelligence make sure to like this
video subscribe to our Channel and share
it with your friends this bgp in Ai and
ml offered in partnership with IBM is
your pathway to become an expert
artificial intelligence and machine
learning professional explore the latest
Technologies and tools for the AI
ecosystem through all this comprehensive
artificial intelligence course gain
insights from master classes conducted
by Caltech facilities and IBM experts
participate in hackathons and engage in
informative ask me anything sessions
elevate your skills and knowledge in the
dynamic field of artificial intelligence
with the industry leading program do
check out the course Link in the
description for more details and if you
wish to learn Ai and become a part of
this amazing technology and become a
thought leader simply learn has just the
right program for you now let's jump
straight ahead one of the most exciting
advancement in AI is the introduction to
Google AI lab the AI lab is a new
Research Center dedicated to pushing the
boundaries of AI Technologies and
developing innovative solutions to real
world problems the AI lab is led by Dr
Fifi Lai who is known for her work in
computer regions and machine learning
one of the standout projects of the AI
lab is the new robotic hand called AI
hand AI hand is a state of the art
robotic hand that has been designed to
be as close to the real human hand as
possible it has 26 joins allowing it to
carry out a variety of complicated
movements and it is even has touch
sensors that allow it to feel object and
its environment the technology behind AI
hand is truly impressive and has the
potential to change the face of Robotics
as we all know it another exciting
project from the AI lab is a new AI
language model called Google Nina Mina
is designed to be as close to human
level language understanding as possible
and it can answer a wide range of
questions with pinpoint accuracy
this technology has the potential to
revolutionarize how we interact with AI
making it more initiative and nature for
humans to communicate with machines
Google is also showcasing a number of AI
advancement including Google Imaging
which is an innovation image generator
that can create incredible realistic
image from text prompts the technology
behind imagine is truly impressive and
has the potential to revolutionize the
world of Art and Design in conclusion
the Google input output 2023 has been a
Showcase of some truly groundbreaking AI
Technologies Google is continuing to
push the boundaries of what is possible
with AI
and it is exciting to see how this
technology will shape the future we are
truly living in the Golden Age of AI and
we can't wait to see what the future
holds so that's all for this video let
us know in the comment section if you
would want to make more such videos on
all the other AI tools announced by
Google thank you and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you